hey you use code al-mar'u in the
fortnight's shop hello and welcome to
Playstation grenade it's time for
another myth chaser episode if you new
around these parts the premise is simple
you comment a question below which tests
the boundaries of fortnight and then we
meet up and we put them into action
hopefully we find a mythical question
which changes how we play the game just
before we start I just want to say thank
you to everyone that has sub to the
channel to get me over 1 million thank
you so much for sticking with me I
really appreciate it before I get
emotional let's do this our first
question comes from Luke Robbins who
says what happens when you shoot a burst
rifle with only one bullet in it that is
a great question what do you think will
happen when a burst rifle fires with
only one bullet so let's try this
we found the weapons of choice and we
whittled down the bullets to only one
and then we noticed something remarkable
even with one single bullet in the
magazine the pulse rifle shoots three
shots we tested this out multiple times
to confirm this but that's not the end
of the myth we wondered if the bullets
hit for the same damage and set up a
friend to be court-martialed and get
this even though the weapon shoots three
times only the first bullets actually
hits the other to become blanks strange
isn't it only the first bullet is alive
round so thank you for your question
Luke you taught us something today next
myth the game guy says myth you won't
take fall damage if you enter a
motorboat before you land interesting
thought my friend we already know that
we can fall into hiding places from
maximum height without taking damage but
what about a boat so in the name of
science
we built an erection so big your mother
would blush and this was my first
attempt
myth confirmed you can indeed save
yourself from fall damage by entering a
boat at the very last millisecond I got
to say this this is hard to do from 10
jumps we made it in twice from Mike's
height anyway the lower the fall the
easier it is to survive but yeah myth
confirmed GG the game guy we can't have
a myth chaser episode without a steamie
stacks myth or two crazy banana is
better than ninja great name
saves myth what happens when you throw a
grenade in steamy stacks
well no setup needed for this one what
do you think will happen will the nade
float or sink in the eaves
well that was anticlimactic the grenade
just sits on the water just like the
husk did last week while we're here
though let's test funky monkeys myth who
says if you bottle flip into the Kevin
liquid in steamy stacks it will not land
sound plausible doesn't it well here we
go and oh oh well the bottle just
ignores the updraft and treats the
purple liquid like a solid floor so
sadly myth busted as we talked about
bottle flips check out this myth from we
be jamming who says it's possible to
land a bottle flip on a rocket hmm wow
this is gonna take a long time to try do
you think it's possible to land a bottle
flip on a rocket well for 30 minutes we
tried this and we failed hard but just
before we were about to call it a day we
got pretty close check this out the
bottle hits the rocket and almost sticks
at this point I really want to give it
another go so I don't wanna say myth
busted just yet so instead I challenge
you to land a bottle flip on a moving
rocket as always if you manage this
please upload it to YouTube and send me
a message on Twitter my name is Adam
grenade and my DMS are always open and
that reminds me the last challenge I
threw your way was to rock it right onto
the zip wire and then rock it right
again straight after that I thought it
was impossible but these guys managed it
weeaboo and bright on rocket duty and
the man who pulled off this stunt is LT
wolf or yes
so lieutenant wolf you are our hero of
the week on the PSD discord well played
guys suddenly we got a myth that looked
so much fun to try demon headmaster as
the good name says can you fishing rod
someone into a rocket but here's the
issue I didn't read it as into a rocket
I read it as onto a rocket so I thought
the question wants to rocket ride after
being fished so this is what happened
[Music]
how a pic was that is such a shame that
the replay file did whatever it's doing
there anyway myth confirmed
oh and to actually address the real myth
that was asked yeah you can definitely
use a fishing rod to pull enemies and
friends into danger here's another great
myth and once again I forgot to write
down the comment I'm I'm very sorry they
asked can the boat attach to the crane
dirty docks eliminate a player I love
this what do you think will happen will
the boat splat my him a or will she
survive unharmed cue the epic music
[Music]
[Music]
nope nope nope nope nope nope nope nope
nope nope
hey she's okay my girls okay great myth
sadly busted but that was enjoyable next
myth comes from claw Jim blob who says
me you can cancel fall damage by landing
on another player hmm this one does have
potential in my eyes can we jump from a
crazy height and survive landing on a
friend the results are very interesting
indeed first we found the perfect height
to be eliminated and then we try to land
on a friend instead of the hard ground
and this happened we survived but we
took heavy damage and to double-check
this we took this to the skies we went
higher and soon realize that the
reduction in damage can't help very much
at all but at the perfect height it's
completely possible to land on a
teammate and survive a death ball so
well played claw Jim blob here's a myth
from all callie graham who says myth a
trap can eliminate a player in a hideout
I'm sure you've given this one or two
goals yourself and the results are very
confusing the first thing we should note
if a player is in a hiding place they
cannot be killed by a trap regardless of
where we put it things get a little more
interesting by placing traps at
different angles depending on how long
the animation takes to get into or out
of the hiding spot it's completely
possible to eliminate a foe jumping in
or out
but traps can't be trusted here take
this example a floor trap and four walls
does not guarantee you a kill a player
can leap out and still be completely
fine there are technically dead zones
around hiding places by dead zones I
mean Undead don't fishing donkey I'm
getting confused let's just move on the
same rules apply to all hiding spots
except the haystacks which become
useless if you place a trap underneath
to activate it simply take out the
hiding spots and you will kill the
person inside next myth
can a bandage bazooka blocker rocket
well this is insanity the first thing we
need to learn is if a rocket can make
contact with a bandage and check this
out it sure can so now it's time to test
it out so we used a disposable storm
trooper and fired live rounds at him
will he survive by bandage blocking
let's find out
good it you know it rip the galactic
dream the bandaged bazooka can not block
rockets but at least it tried ok so now
let's try something monumental je Otley
says can you tie a game with the last
two players hmm can we have two winners
in a game of fortnight I tried a few
different ways to get this to happen and
the most reliable was to have 2 players
killed by a third-person trap at the
exact same moment using a custom game
three of us met up and made a death trap
which was activated by one guy
eliminated themselves leaving two people
alive who do you think will win or will
this be a tie well he may get this or
will the girl from frozen get this let
it go
[Music]
well who'd have thunk it the chance of
winning is completely random we tried
this multiple times with multiple
players from different areas of the
world and on different pings and in
different regions
it seems that though bad ping or
terrible latency will give you a
slightly better chance of winning but
not every time so to address the
original question no it's not possible
to tie a game random choice will dictate
the winner and just before the last myth
a quick thank you to those who have used
my code in the last week of November I'd
really appreciate it and also to those
who leave a myth in the comments thank
you so much family okay so it's time the
last myth
I earn Rajesh Kumar says what happens
when PlayStation granade plays on an
Xbox whoo for you Arjen I'll do it we're
all gamers right